so at what point in time did you uh
because obviously there was the ybn
split cordae dropped the ybn from his
name everyone's still cool you know
everyone's still kosher but like you
kind of just dove in with core day so
what was like the
the like obviously chordates [__] you
know generationally talented guys great
great kid like what was it about chord A
that made you want to like really focus
on him
as a client
like once I already
was working with all three of the guys
yeah yeah
he was focused he wanted to be great he
wants to be great he still does but I'm
saying like I noticed that from the very
moment that I started working with chord
A
our conversations were different than
what I was having with Jay and Amir you
know
um and I mean look to like Jay and
amir's defense like namir never like
wanted to be like a professional rapper
right right namir always made music even
when he was younger but like he didn't
have like that like that bug you know
like burning desire you want to be
famous he wants to be famous yeah he
must be famous yeah yeah actually yeah
and he got famous and then it was just
like he's like what the [__] do I do now
right and everything was happening so
fast damir always just wanted to be a
kid he just wanted to be famous while
doing it right
the industry doesn't really allow you to
do that right right once you have a real
demand like it becomes a business right
so you struggle with that Jay
always just wanted to [__] [__] so
like and he's successful once he
achieved that was he was successful at
that it was hard to keep him
Focus
corday always was like he would wake up
and go to sleep just talking about like
rap music ideas and like what's the next
step and like yo I did this I did that
I'm going to meet with this person I was
networking with this person today this
person hit me up yo what do you think
about this record everything was just
music music so he was focused was it his
idea to do the uh J Cole reply it was he
we were living together at the time he
was living upstairs in my life he came
downstairs one morning I woke up he came
downstairs
he said yo I was thinking
mind you I never even heard the J Cole
1985 man yeah I never heard 1985.
um
he came downstairs like yo you know the
1985 record by J Cole I'm like that's on
his new project now I ain't heard it
he's like well basically it's like he's
touching upon like how this new era of
Youth in rappers and kind of like what
you would consider to be the SoundCloud
era he's like my generation how
everyone's kind of lost you know a lot
of the mistakes we're making they're not
gonna last you know
I feel like making a response for that
on behalf of like my peers and my
generation the youth explaining to him
and even just those who represent that
older generational mentality like this
is why we do this right why don't you
look at it from our perspective and I'm
like sounds dope killed it but I never
heard the originals right I'm just
supporting I'm like go do it when he
came back and played me the record I
still never heard the Jake Owen I was
just like yo this is wild yeah without
even knowing the yeah I would just say
the narration of it is bridging like
this separation in this Gap that was
becoming like really really obvious that
sounds aware between traditional of
course yeah that was like SoundCloud
[__] and it was like yeah yeah and I
mean there wasn't even anybody who was
doing real rap from the new school at
the time nobody nobody was making
traditional hip-hop for sure yeah he was
like oh wait this kid's 18 and he's
[__] rapping over Eminem and yeah
yeah so I was like that all that
collectively kind of was what made me
really really focus on core day because
I have a job to do and quite frankly
like people in my position we Empower
those who allow us to do our job and
who see there who take their job
seriously what is like for people who
don't know what a manager does in a like
a role like yourself what is like your
duties as a manager like for people who
are interested in maybe getting into the
music industry or you know
I think I think that
the job description itself
has a few
kind of
unwavering core responsibilities for
everybody right no matter what client
you represent because it does vary right
of course of course but managing
relationships
management relationships first and
foremost right you don't even have to
like your manager if you're doing your
job as an artist and your manager is
good at managing relationships you guys
can be extremely successful together
you know what I'm saying because as an
artist it's like
you're the centerpiece like you're
you're the engine of the vehicle like
what you do determines if it goes or not
if your manager is good at managing
relationships people he's likeable he's
Dependable he's charismatic right he's
genuine he's friendly he does good
business by thinking about what the the
other party is getting out of every
equation not just what you guys are
getting so that people see him as fair
you guys can be great together right
that's first second I think that your
manager has to have
if you're managing a this is the
difference right managing a rapper is
different if you're managing an artist
right
then I think that there has to be a
vision attached to it because
there have there has to be a long-term
goal not just nearsighted
accomplishments right as the focus
what do you think of rappers right and
this isn't to discredit anybody but this
is just like if you this is just a fact
there's country artists pop artists
reggae artists
hip-hop artists
right right
when they say rappers it's kind of
because like rap is the evolution of
hip-hop it kind of created its own image
almost like its own genre it's like it
came kind of with the evolution of
production right so like
not necessarily bass lines but like 808s
right incentives and different things
like that and then the concepts in the
subject matter of what rap talks about
hip-hop stems from like black and brown
people coming from like inner cities in
in just places in America where your
voices you couldn't be heard right you
didn't fit a certain political stature
economic stature so through break
dancing and graffiti and song form
people would listen now DJing party DJ
yeah people listen up but then rappers
the evolution that where it's like it
represents
black and brown people who have now
achieved those things that we need to
have now now you have well now you have
money now you have a political stature
right so it's like we can talk about
different subject matters like cars and
Wealthy all these different glorified
things we never used to see Raps like
the evolution of hip-hop so I feel like
if you're managing rappers the landscape
of what that lifestyle entails you can
be in the clubs like you can do features
for money you set up bags
bro like in like yo [__]
getting rich out here and I love that
[__] that's what I love about how
hip-hop has evolved to rap but
in some of the other genres the
traditional genres of like hip-hop
country Pop
um you know reggae r b whatever there
has to be kind of a more long-term goal
that's attached to it
because
those are not cash out genres like rap
has become right and that's why rap is
so saturated it's because there's enough
money in it to satisfy everybody